- So what tree does this grow off of?
- Tree? Corn!
- Oh. That's (laughs).
(bubbly pop music)
- My favorite fast food
nachos are actually Chipotle.
- Chipotle's gonna have the best.
- 7Eleven might pull through.
- No.
(bubbly pop music)
- The tortilla looks fresh.
- A lot of these chips are pretty
sparse in the cheese department.
- Not very cheesy
- They taste really good.
- The cheese is that
Chipotle cheese that I love.
- I can taste the lime in there.
- If you like suck on it.
- Well, suck on it.
- (laughs)
- These look promising.
- This one you can see there's
different types of cheese.
- This one looks like has a lot of oil.
- I dig that.
- I'm into it too.
The cheese is like a good
mixture of kinds of cheeses.
- It makes me wanna drink beer.
- I've never had Del Taco, but
I feel like this is Del Taco.
- They look like they have
density to it, not too thin.
- This is like you could
scoop some stuff in this.
- Gorgeous! (squeals) Gorgeous!
- Mmm, crunch!
- These are really tasty.
- Oh, this is definitely Chipotle.
- These are Chipotle chips 100%.
- I feel like the chip is
overpowering the cheese.
- I can't even find the cheese in here.
- This is in the lead.
- I feel like these are
7Eleven off the bat.
- They look really 7Eleven-y.
- What kind of cheese is on this?
Is it like--
- It's plastic.
- I like this cheese.
- You're so weird.
- Ooh! The cheese is spicy.
- Spicy! Spicy!
- Oh I like the spice.
That surprised me.
- These look better because
it's the same fake cheese,
but the chips look a lot stronger.
- These are the whitest
chips I've ever seen.
(crunch)
- I like this.
- I was just gonna say, if you like
the fake liquid cheese, you
probably will like these.
- It's not bad.
You could actually like
dip it with anything.
- I think these are the best nachos,
and I think it's from Chipotle.
- I also think these were the best.
And I also think they're from Chipotle.
- These are my favorite nachos.
- I'm gonna pick this one.
- [Voiceover] That's Taco Bell.
- That's Taco Bell?
- Taco Bell!
- Go Taco Bell.
- Thank you.
- Taco Bell
nachos were way better
than I expected them to be.
- Taco Bell's bomb.
- [Voiceover] Del Taco.
(yell)
- They're from Del Taco?
- Which one's Chipotle?
These are.
(buzz)
- These?
(ding)
- You go, Del Taco!
- Good for you.
- This is not Mexican but this is good.